there are the updated odds for the third
pick in the draft my how it has changed
just a couple of weeks ago trey lance
was the favorite to go number three then
after the trade settled in that rocketed
the 49ers from 12-3
mack jones became the prohibitive
favorite at minus 200.
now justin fields on the heels of pro
day 2
he's the favorite to be the third
overall pick by the san francisco 49ers
hey peter
king i'll say this if the 49ers
are trying to build a mystery as to what
they're going to do with that third
overall pick
mission accomplished because at this
point no one knows what they're doing
i mean it's all nonsensical to me
and not that uh so much of pre-draft
stuff is nonsensical
but the reason that it's nonsensical is
that
do you think that if mac jones had had a
pro day this
this week and kyle shanahan and john
lynch were standing there on the
sidelines
do you think that those odds would be
the same
no i don't i mean i i don't understand
why
going to a pro day and look
whoever makes those odds could very well
know something
i don't know i don't know anything
though
and and and it it just seems a little
silly
that you know the fact that you had
these guys
standing there at a pro day watching a
workout
they now oh boy now they're picking
justin fields
it just mike it's just silly it's
all you never that's all i can do i hear
what you're saying it's silly
i i don't know enough yet about the
gambling philosophies to know
what makes the odds moves obviously
betting on one specific guy will change
the odds and it could be that just a
bunch of
casual gamblers are making that
extremely superficial connection
there he is mask up kyle please kyle
kyle i've told you three times
now this week mask up of course it's the
same clip but i'll say it again
mask up um it could just be people are
making that very obvious connection and
that's driving the numbers and
it really isn't any different it's gonna
settle back into mac jones
being the favorite i think that a lot of
us like it being mysterious especially
the networks that are going to televise
the draft we already know one and two
why would why would we want the 49ers to
tell us who number three is but they run
the risk eventually peter
of looking like they traded up to number
three without knowing what they were
going to do
that that's the danger of making it too
mysterious because at some point you say
guys you're ultimately investing three
first round picks and a third round pick
for a player
and you don't know who the player is
really
it could be one of three guys and you
haven't decided yet
i mean i think they've known all along
and they're just doing their due
diligence
because you never know what's going to
happen and in theory anything can happen
in the next 13 days
that could cause them to pivot away from
the guy that they traded up there to get
so uh peter i i think it's a combination
of the ultimate reality show getting
hyped up
in a subtle way or not and the 49ers
just being careful because they can be
look there's no reason why the san
francisco 49ers
need to let anything leak about who
they're taking
no reason whatsoever and
you know as far as what happened
one month before the draft i believe
that chris greer played this situation
the miami general manager
played this situation perfectly
because he basically said to the 49ers
and the 49ers knew
that if we want to go up and get this
pick
we have to overpay nobody's ever gone up
nine spots in a first round and paid
two future ones and a three to do it
nobody this is a tremendous
investment and in my opinion what the
49ers did was
they ensured that they bought insurance
that they were going to get one of those
three guys and although i believe
on the day they did this that kyle
shanahan's voice
deep inside is saying hey we're taking
mac jones
but john lynch adam peters paragmarate
jed york hey listen
we've got a month let's study
every guy thoroughly and let's make sure
that when we do
pick the guy and and look this is
there's all kinds of great memes
[Laughter]
if you have if you have a month
if you have a month you should use every
every moment because you're making a
momentous decision
for the future of your franchise yeah
and
one thing that we talked about when
kyle shanahan went to pro day 2 in
alabama to see mac jones throw
shanahan doesn't like going to pro days
he doesn't go to many so he goes to see
mac jones in alabama he goes to see
justin fields
in columbus he's going to go see trey
lance at his pro day two
yeah i i think that you just you just
want
to feel better you already feel good
about it you wouldn't have made the move
this is a way for you to feel
better you've seen mac jones throw on
the field
in person you've done it with fields
you've done it with lands you have
greater conviction in what you're going
to do
they really don't have to be coy because
it's not like anyone is going to
leapfrog them nobody's trading up to two
with the jets
to take mack jones the jets are locked
in with zach wilson
the jaguars are locked in with trevor
lawrence the 49ers basically have the
first pick in the draft as far as anyone
knows
so they don't need to be coy but you
need to be ready you never know what's
going to happen peter i just think
that's what it comes down to whether
it's the laramie tunsil
gas mask bong video or
you know i look i don't i don't want to
get specific and then be accused of
jinxing someone
but 13 days are going to elapse
between now and the first round of the
draft and
the you know
maybe mac jones isn't completely healthy
13 days from now and you got to be ready
to move on to plan b
you don't know what's gonna happen fluke
freak accidents
happen all the time to people
yeah i just got a text from somebody
saying what do you mean
what do the 49ers have to gain by
keeping it secret
i'll give you a great for instance
suppose the atlanta falcons
not that i think this is going to happen
suppose the atlanta falcons are in love
with
pick a quarterback justin fields and
they hear
that the 49ers very well might pick
justin fields
and what if the atlanta falcons say to
the 49ers
look we'll give you a two to go up to
number three
and the 49ers say will only do that
if you uh you know if we can be assured
that we're going to get the guy we want
it for and they play that dance they
play that game
it's almost certain not to happen but
the reason why you keep
things a secret is that you never can
tell
what is going to happen on you know in
the day or two before the draft
and i'll give you a great example i was
with the 49ers in their draft room
you know on in 2017 the first draft for
john
lynch there and they basically took
advantage
of not took advantage but they basically
squeezed out another third round pick
from the bears to move up from three to
two
to get mitchell trubisky and and so
when you basically uh
are in this position the way that the
49ers are now
you need to play your cards incredibly
close to the vest
so that no one knows until you make the
pick
exactly what you're going to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports